men they don't so much need love they
want respect if they had to choose
between love and respect from their mate
they would choose respect women need
love they want to be loved and adored
and everything else men different so I
had a psychotherapist called Adam Lane
Smith on my podcast and he said that
male depression gets treated like female
depression men are made to feel loved
and accepted when all they want to do is
feel capable and Powerful he used this
example of the Blitz in World War II
before the war started there were these
psychiatric Wards and they had patience
and these patients had been totally
comatose unresponsive then the blitz
starts so there were fires and there
were injuries all over London and there
were ambulances and fire engines and
there was no one to drive that these men
got up and started driving fire engines
and ambulances these men that had been
unresponsive for years and years and
years and give a man a purpose and the
ability to achieve it and he will crawl
over broken glass with a smile